[Musique]
vous l'avez peut-être remarqué récemment
il ya plusieurs biens et services qui
coûte plus cher
le prix de la viande fromage mais aussi
des meubles et surtout de l'essence
augmenté par rapport à l'année dernière
et c'est seule l'inflation la hausse des
prix en général dans le temps pour
suivre son évolution statistique canada
à mesure comment le prix des biens
courants varie d'une année à l'autre est
en fait un indice seul indice des prix à
la consommation
par exemple on peut évaluer qu'un même
panier d'épicerie de 100 dollars en 1980
coûte aujourd'hui 320 dollars
ces pigments au risque d'une
augmentation annuelle de l'inflation de
2 % pour garder l'économie stable et
prévisible mais au-delà de 2% qu'est-ce
qui se passe
dans sa touche tout le monde mais s'il y
en a qui en souffrent davantage c'est
clair quand on passe surtout quand on
parle de nourriture c'est les ménages
qui sont plus pauvres qu'ils font c'est
quand même plus grande partie de leurs
dépenses à acheter la nourriture dans le
passé des périodes de grande inflation
ont déstabilisé l'économie comme dans
les années soixante dix une période de
chocs pétroliers ont fait exploser non
seulement les prix du carburant qu'est
ce que tu veux monter je reste c'est le
style mais aussi les clients génial
savez vous que le prix du lait a demandé
ce matin encore encore
l'inflation est galopante pendant plus
de dix ans et il y à une anomalie bien
que les prix ne cessent d'augmenter la
croissance elle est au ralenti on
appelle ça la stagflation et la solution
va venir des états unis au début des
années 80 avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt ils dansent sas a aussi un
effet secondaire l'effet secondaire
c'est quoi c'est de créer une récession
donc ils ont causé chômage perte
d'emploi et ce sont donc des difficultés
économiques aujourd'hui on est bien loin
de connaître une inflation semblable à
celle des années 70 mais on connaît
aussi une situation inusitée avec la
coved bien qu'on se relève à peine d'une
crise les gens ont d'elle et arguent ils
peuvent dépenser et ça c'est
complètement atypique on n'aurait jamais
vu ça dans une récession précédente et
la raison pour ça ce sont les programmes
day qui ont été mises en place donc on
se retrouve maintenant au moment d'une
reprise avec des gens qui ont beaucoup
de liquidités et j'irai la crainte
principale des économistes pour une
inflation à plus long terme ce serait
que ses liquidités comment dire sont
libérés très rapidement et que les gens
se mettent à consommer très rapidement
sans que l'offre de plus suite il faut
plusieurs économistes estiment que
l'actuel inflation et seulement
transitoire quel est le signe anormal
d'une reprise après les premiers mois de
la pandémie où les prix ont même décidé
je regarde où était le niveau des prix
en février 2020 par rapport au niveau
des prix juillet 2021 il y a eu
effectivement une augmentation des prix
à un taux de presque exactement 2 % on
s'était du rattrapage mais maintenant
donc la grande question c'est est-ce que
ça va persister encore longtemps l'effet
des spirales n'est pas impossible
honnêtement si les travailleurs
demandent à être compensée pour les
relations on oppose d'équivalent
historiques sur lesquels se basait pour
dire voici ce qui va se produire donc
pas encore une énorme inquiétude mais
c'est sûr que c'est un indicateur qui
qui nous préoccupe et que sur lesquels
on garde un oeil ouvert et pour
compliquer le tout si la banque du
canada a décidé d'augmenter son taux
directeur pour freiner l'inflation les
taux hypothécaires augmenterait aussi
dans un contexte où la dette
hypothécaire des canadiens ne jamais
quitter aussi
[Musique]